From building dams rivers to changing the chemistry of the atmosphere, human beings were strong
Impact on our planet. But what would happen if we suddenly disappeared?
The first few weeks will be chaos. Within hours, power plants run out of fuel
And off. As the lights went out and electricity fences lost a bite, more than one and a half
Billion cows, nearly a billion pigs and more 20 billion chickens and out of
Its annexes, desperate for food. Without any humans to feed them, most of these cattle
Will starve to death, or become food for more than half a billion dogs and an almost equal number of
Cats who now have to defend themselves. Of course, many of our fancy breeds are inappropriate
For life in the wild, it may be outcompeted by more solid boobies, not to mention
Wolves, Wolves and Wild Cats. Other animals that depend on humans, from rats to cockroaches,
Will suffer a drastic decline in population. Some, such as body lice and head lice, will go extinct.
In the cities, many of our famous streets now have rivers. Without electric pumps
Keep them dry and subway underground tunnels will
Fill with water quickly. Other streets will disappear with herbs and vineyards, followed by
Of plants and large trees.
But before that happens, most cities will be wiped out by fire. Modern houses, especially
In the suburbs, most of them are still made of wood. And with no firefighters around, one
Thunderbolt is all it takes to start a fire that can burn all the divisions
on the earth. In the countryside, many wood structures will be destroyed within a few
Contracts, if not for fire, then of termites and other analyzers.
After 100 years most of the wooden structures will have been finished, and anything made of steel - from
Apartment buildings in cars and even bridges - are not
So much. Steel is mostly iron, without static
Apply paints and coatings, and will react quickly with oxygen in the atmosphere
Back to its original shape of iron oxide, or rust.
By that time human beings have gone for a few hundred years and most species of animals
Around the world - at least, they do not have to go to extinction - will have bounced
To them they were the levels before they evolved.
But its distribution will forever change.
Camels are now scouring Australia, while in North America dozens of species of imported birds are imported
Of Europe will continue to flourish. It's even possible that in some parts of the world,
Park animals escape can form new wild species, leading to the possibility of black on the big
Plains, or hippos in rivers in South America.
Forever proliferating across space will be the electromagnetic radiation we created from
We have radios, satellites and telephones.
But if anything will last us on the ground, it may be our garbage. Chemical Links That
Holding together plastic or vulcanized rubber are safe from most digestive enzymes
Used by bacteria to break down natural polymers and unlike metals, plastics do not rust or
Eat. These microplastics escape into the watercourses or drift along in the ocean and they end up
Deposited in sediments. Hundreds of millions of years from now, alien geologists from outer space
Space may be surprised to find sedimentary rocks full of small carbon particles
Which were once part of rubber tires or plastic bags.
Of course, whether something remains largely depends on the circumstances. It will be everything
Another much longer in the desert, where there is none
Moisture to accelerate rust or support decomposing organisms. And while the carbon cycle will
Return CO2 levels to balance after a few thousand years, and long-term domestic deposits
Organic chemicals or radioactive materials can last for a very, very long time.
It is hard to know what future foreign paleontologists will make of us. how will
Explain our love of plastic or the fact that it is within
The geological eyeblink we exploded outside Africa to
Colonize almost all residential space on the ground. But they will certainly ask
Why, if we have been very successful for a long time, we disappeared
Quickly.
This episode was brought to you by Squarespace.com. If you ever wanted to make your own website,
Squarespace recently launched the latest version of their program, Squarespace 7, which has
Fully redesigned interface, integration with Getty and Google apps, new templates,
An incredible feature called Cover Pages. You can start a free trial at Squarespace.com/asap
If you decide to subscribe, use the code display asap at checkout to get 10% off. thanks
Back to Squarespace to support our offer.
And if you have not seen our latest AsapTHOUGHT video on why we misunderstood songs, you can check
That going out with a link in the description as well - should give you a laugh
Hopefully help solve some of your brain secrets on music.
Subscribe to get more weekly flag videos!